mr. president five minutes sir
evening ma'am Merry Christmas Mike
Mustang mrs. Big Top bringing out the
full package where'd that come from
everybody knows you did the right thing
on that bridge I mean the president
knows you got to learn how to get back
into the real world
mr. president we're ready for you our
guests have arrived
I'd like to welcome in the White House
sir
so there's been an incursion let's got
move
give me the Pentagon on the line now
Olympus is falling
Olympus flat
mr. speaker you are the acting president
I want to speak for the Russians the
Chinese the British and French in that
honor if you attempt to retake this
building now let's would you your
commander in chief we have contact from
inside the White House identify yourself
3:09 er Jesus banning the same guy that
was removed from the president's detail
he is ex Special Forces 40 commandos
breached the gate 28 who left can we
trust him
with all due respect
I'm the best hope you've got
about the safety of the President of the
United
we're talking about a lot more than that
sir
[Music]
just open the gates of hell
United States of America doesn't
negotiate with terrorists
who said anything about negotiating
you
[Music]